hey there Akuma fans Charlie with the
gosar application staff got another
video for you today and this time we're
going to talk about broaching I've had
quite a few customers that have uh ask
me yeah how in the world can I cut a
keyway brooch in my part and um It's
seems simple enough but um there's some
ins and outs that we definitely want to
talk about so let's start by talking
about the way we're going to hold on to
a brooch uh if you have a rotary brooch
you're doing an entire ID Dynamite go
for it knock yourself out those things
are awesome you can just simply position
it uh do all of the the Preamble stuff
that the manufacturer recommends slight
taper on the beginning of the hole come
in at an aggressive uh feed rate so that
the the rotary bro won't double clutch
and then simply feed forward and allow
ow the wobbling of the bearing on the
brooch to uh to do its thing I could go
into that for hours and hours and hours
but let's talk about what the uh uh what
the rest of us are going to do that
don't own a wobble brooch I'm going to
run over to my collision avoidance
screen right here and let's Zoom all the
way back out so that we can see what
I've set up there we have just a regular
turning tool
holder and
uh there we go so I've got
a graphic representation of a maybe a
callit Chuck or a um a tool block
somehow I've held on to this chunk of
rectangular keyway stock that's been
sharpened into a brooch that's uh you
know that's that's the down and dirty
nitty-gritty that that's you know the
usual way that we're going to make this
uh make this brooch happen so now we got
to talk about how to program this and
I've made several different uh examples
that we're going to take a look at uh by
the way before I I Tango off on to that
you'll notice that I did put this in a
solid boring bar holder it's not
recommended for you to do a static
Broach like this uh with a live tool you
think oh hey I got a live tool it's got
a call it in it boom I'm
done no the the bearings of a live tool
are really not designed to take this
kind of U
uh ra axial load when the bearings
aren't rotating you're you're probably
going to pit your bearings or the races
and not something I want to do so I put
this in a static holder clamped on it
good and tight because of course the the
pressure in the z+ direction is going to
be pretty significant so we want to make
sure that it's good and tight and no
bearings to give us a rough time so
let's go and look at a couple of my
different programs here first one is
just it's probably the
easiest and uh what I did was called up
the tool had an M5 now this example is
assuming that you are able to put this
this keyway at any location inside the
uh the ID and that's the one we're doing
we're doing an ID keyway OD we'll use an
endmill or Square the corner whatever so
we're doing the inside and a nice little
key cut so this is assuming I can put it
anywhere in the inside of the part or uh
I'm limited to
c0 so I've thrown in an m19 to orient
the spindle and it'll hold it in place
for me WRA it it to the position of the
um start of the ID which in my case
let's zip back over here you can see
I've got I've already bored and turned
and the the parts just simply ready for
brooch so I'll go to my 1in diameter
which is the basically the ID of the
bore kick into g94 mode this is
important because the spindles aren't
turning therefore you need to have
inches per minute feed rate specified
not inches per Revolution and in this
case I'm just doing a
g74 that's the the normal face pecking
cycle there is the final diameter not
the radius the final diameter of the
groove so by saying I'm going to 1 and
A4 in on the ID that means this is going
to be an E8 inch deep uh radial deep uh
keyway that's what I'm trying to say
depth of the groove there the I value
that I have this is the amount of um
Step Up obviously I can't just take this
brooch and go an eighth of an inch and
blast it no not unless I'm Machining
butter or
margarine maybe Jell-O but the surface
finish in Jell-O isn't all that good so
we're going to go 20,000 set a pop this
is probably because of the the depth
that I've specified here we're probably
doing aluminum or plastic if you're
doing something greater than that you're
going to have to go down into the
thousands or the tenths uh in order to
make this
happen and I have chosen in this case to
do an actual pecking motion into this
part so my parts here I'm going to go to
the depth and I'm going to Peck at it
like so uh if this is a work hardening
material obviously I don't want to do
that we're going to experiment with that
in just a second so I'm going to go
20,000 per PEC and then it's doing a
short
retract the L value is how far to go
into the part before it retracts all the
way back out for the subsequent PEC in
this case I don't want the tool to come
all the way back out there's a chance
that it could yeah do something funky so
I want to keep the keyway in there
therefore I'm telling it hey don't
retract all the way I've made the L
value greater than the entire depth of
my um of my keyway and a feed rate I'm
picking 50 Ines a minute right now
obviously I don't have to worry about
feeds and speeds and surface finishes
and that stuff so I'm happy and then
once that cycle is done I simply retract
and go home let's see what it does for
us so now we'll come into our automatic
mode and we will hit cycle slam and of
course my spindle inter ha my cais is
still on hey how many of you ever have
to deal with that okay so manual mode
turn off my cais we are good to go let's
give it a shot okay now it orients and
let's blow this up so you can see what
it's
doing it is pecking so let's let's do a
single block and slow things down so
that you can actually see the peck
otherwise my graphics card is just not
quite doing it there we go we got a feed
and a peack and a feed and a pack and so
forth and so on
now that you see it let's take off the
single block let's talk about what it's
doing so here I am at
1.1 and then it's going to retract and
go to 1.5 again that's a diametrical
value so we're actually only doing
25,000 per side now one thing that you
will notice about this is when we get to
the hole the
depth keep going keep going keep going
[Music]
almost okay so you notice it did not
move down in X for the retract it's
retracting straight out of the hole okay
fine I whatever I might be dragging the
uh the the tip of the brooch a little
bit but you know whatevers yo if that's
not desirable I do have some other
cycles that will retract let's talk
about those here in just a second I want
to show you a couple of the the options
that I can make happen with this
particular version of the program let's
get back in here and you notice that I
did my I of 005 if I did not want to uh
take too much let's drop this down to
something like U oh
5,000 and I'm going to Omit this little
the little pecking action that I have
here and I can do that simply by making
the D also greater than the total length
of travel of the machine not the machine
the part be
specific now when we run it even if we
did it in single block you would see
that the the tool just goes all the way
down no Peck basically I've just turned
my lathe into a shaper from
1942 I think that's pretty cool but
obviously if I'm doing that I'm going to
take a a much finer PEC but the result
is the same it is going to bro in
retract move out broo in retract move
out so forth and so
on okay let's speed that up so that I
can get on to my next example so now
we're going to start exploring some of
the other options that Akuma gives
us keep going keep going keep going keep
going the next uh for the next example
I'm going to throw a curveball into this
and say Hey My My keyway cannot be at or
is not called out at c0 it's at C90 so
what do I do now because m19 is only
going to go to c0 what the heck can I do
about that let's go ahead and abort this
little process right here we will get
the tool out of the
way and look at the next example a
brooch with an m110 in there so this is
going to give me the ability to turn on
the c-axis and Orient this part so that
the brooch will go wherever the the
process tells me the basics let's open
up the the first one so that we can
compare it with this one so the basics
are exactly the same but instead of the
m19 I'm going into
m110 all right close the other one
you'll notice here that I have a um an
M13 sb1000 that's the the command to
fire up the live tool I told you not to
use us a live tool didn't I well what
the heck is my problem when there is a
solid block on there this is going to
fire up the live tooling
motor but it's not connected to anything
so the whole point of this is there is
an interlock in this machine that when
you're in m110 mode it will not allow
feed motion unless the spindle rotating
it's a little safety thing yeah all
right awesome there is a code this
little guy right here
m808 that will ignore this interlock
that's causing us problems uh okay great
so why do I have both just to show you
uh uh my particular simulator does not
have the option for m108 or 808 uh
interlock release so just wanted to show
you that either one of these is going to
be necessary because we either have to
have a spindle rotating even though it's
not turning the tool it's just turning
the motor that's supposed to be
connected to the tool or the m108 808
boy that's like the second time I've
said
that it's been a long day
already then I'm going to use the
G13 cycle for this particular example I
do have a couple more that we'll do but
let's uh let's just talk about the g183
that's your regular live tooling PEC
drilling cycle so in this case I don't
have the
uh ability to just tell it to move out
with each subsequent pass so I've added
X values for each subsequent and still
the same thing with the D and the L if
we want to PE as we're doing the brooch
we can make these lower than the the
actual travel of the part or in this
case I said hey Peck at it so let's see
what this guy does it's pretty much the
same thing as what we saw previously but
this time
you'll notice my
c ah I didn't put the C value in here ah
you caught me here I was trying to get
all cocky in my cycle I better put the
capsul loog C90
Dimension now that I've done that if I
select and quit now you'll see hopefully
Charlie did his homework we'll be able
to see
that my cais is still
connected and now my auto
mode there we go now our c is at 90 hey
Hallelujah I just scrapped apart I
better go tell the boss
honey bad joke and now as I'm stepping
out with each subsequent X pass
everybody's happy once again uh to beat
a dead horse if I did not want it to PE
at each pass and just do the shaper
action just make the D as large as
larger than the total travel of the the
feature okay so now one more for you
this one is going to take care of a
little more uh a little more technical
stuff than the g183 will here I am using
the s sp1000 or the m808 whichever one I
want once again repeating where the the
boore is going to be this time we're
going to use a g190 cycle and I don't
need
cut all that subsequent
stuff so g190 is a keyway cutting cycle
that's designed to be used with a live
an
endmill but in our case we're using it
for a brooch why not the uh basic
integers that need to go in there the
same as everything we've done previously
we've got an X that's the final diameter
the depth of the hole the C location the
I that is the um distance from where the
tool is now to where the uh the uh axis
cut is going to start D that's my depth
of cut for each one l once again is the
uh the retract
value U
it gives me a finish allowance kick butt
it's going to pull out that finish
allowance uh on its final pass but this
gives me a nice little little clean
finish for the final move a feed rate
and then you have the m211 and
m213 the uh the 211 can be either a
um 211 meaning I am cutting in One
Direction or 212 which is I'm cutting in
two directions
if you're cutting in two directions I
really hope that this is like a Groove
tool that has the ability to do a zigzag
but yeah in my case I don't have that
this is simply a piece of tool steel
with a sharpened end so m211 is implying
that I'm only cutting in One Direction
and then I'll do my retract and
reciprocate the m213 or m214 is a
designation for The Cutting method it's
whether you are not whether your infeed
is going to to be a um uh designated or
it's going to be an
equal oh what does that mean yeah well
equal in feed is simply meaning that um
you are doing the same cut in or out or
you are doing a um a designated which
means you are reducing with each in and
out we're using M21 who cares we're
going to leave it uh for this argument
21213 let's just hold that as our our
standard let's go ahead and select and
quit save the program and let's see what
happens with this one blow it up you
notice that it feeds in let's slow it
down and do our single block so that we
can talk about it there is my feed out
to
1.12 it fed in next
execution retract back to my initial
Lane and comes back out to the Z of
point1 so here we have turn off single
block and just Let It Rock here we have
a nice delightful little shaping cycle
with one line so the big choice for most
of you is do I want the tool to retract
after every pass or am I just satisfied
with the retract being right where the
the the cut cycle was there you go we
have our
three just to refresh we got standard
brooch where I use the
g74 one where I'm using m110 so that I
can clock the
spindle and uh the g190 cycle now before
I sign off and do my usual you know like
And subscribe
pandering uh somebody is bound to ask
hey wait a second can't you use the m110
to clock with the G7 74 pecking cycle
nope nope it won't do that it's because
you're specifying two different
platforms to be operating in g73 and g74
is a turning cycle m110 is the uh the
live tooling cycle so now you've got a
contradiction you're saying hey let's
speak Spanish
bonjour yeah not compatible so that's
why I have those three different styles
they uh they each will SA safy a
different need that you may have coming
up and if you have any questions please
reach out to your local gosar
application staff we're always here to
help thanks